delegates from the world's developing
countries are gathering in Cuba the
group of 77 represents 80 percent of the
planet's population it's known as the
g77 this year's Focus will be on trade
and Technology our Latin America editor
Lucia Newman reports from Havana
leaders of the world the world's largest
intergovernmental organization have
arrived in Havana for the South Summit
the top decision-making body of the
group of 77.
the g77 was formed in 1964 within the
United Nations system by 77 developing
countries that were demanding a new
international economic order to give
them effective control over their
natural resources today it's expanded to
134 members
the organization's goal is to allow
these emerging countries from the
so-called Global South to join forces to
articulate and promote their economic
interests as well as strengthen their
joint negotiating power on economic
issues within the UN system not a formal
block
or is a negotiating block which is very
important at the time of negotiations
inside the United Nations and all the
different uh
um technical apparatuses that form part
of the United Nations
China has been providing consistent and
economic support to the g77 since 1994
but it does not consider itself to be a
member that's why the meeting of the
South Summit is called g77 plus China
this year's Summit theme chosen by the
host Cuba is to improve trade technology
transfer and Innovation for developing
countries
one of the most important chasms and
inequalities in the international order
is the exclusion of the countries of the
global South in processes of developing
knowledge and access to Science and
Technology
promoting South to South cooperation is
also a top goal in many ways the g77 is
the flip side of the G7 the club of the
world's most developed economies but
while the group of 77 may not be the
richest countries in terms of GDP
together they had the most resources a
none too small fact that reminds them of
their strength in numbers
Lucy and Newman Al Jazeera Havana
a Walden Bellow is the founder and
co-chair person to focus on the global
South that's a research and advocacy
Institute he's also an international
Adjunct professor of Sociology at the
State University of New York that's in
Binghamton and you're joining us from
Bangkok today sir what does the g77
believe in what does it want
well I think that the g77 has always
stood for non-alignment in great power
conflicts and also it it wants respect
in global Affairs and also wants to make
sure that
its Economic Development or the economic
development of these countries can
proceed without hindrance from the big
powers and so the g77 is maybe of
limited political power but basically
symbolically
it represents really what countries in
the South are aiming for which is much
faster development as well as
non-interference in both their political
and economic Affairs particularly from
the West you mentioned non-alignment
that's a concept that arose during the
Cold War when the world was being pulled
between East and West between the U.S
and the Soviet Union is it is that still
a relevant concept today
uh yes
um it is still a relevant concept I
think that uh we've seen how
um if I'm not mistaken most of the
g77 countries have not allowed
themselves to be pulled into the
conflict in the Ukraine uh basically
they
um yes many of them did condemn Russian
and Russian but beyond that in terms of
either being pro-russian or pro-west
they most of them have really not uh
have not been pushed into a position on
that and they refuse to be pushed into a
position on that they're concerned at
this point when it comes to the Ukraine
Russian conflict is that they continue
to get the supplies of grain
from the Ukraine and from Russia and
that the war does not enter interfere
with this which is the reason why many
of these countries have been constantly
calling for peace and negotiations
between Ukraine and Russia because it is
affecting their food supplies and they
want to make sure that you know they you
know that the the supplies continue to
go to them without interference and and
this is why they've taken quite a
neutral position when it comes to the
conflict between Ukraine and Russia and
in fact they have resisted tremendous
pressure from the United States and the
West to side with Ukraine
Walden Bellow founder and co-chair
person have focused on the global South
thank you for joining us on the program
today
thank you for inviting me